.
Baustelle pur.
- Baustelle pur.
Marco und Dianne Schommer besuchen in
Ruanda ihr zukünftiges Fitnessstudio.
Ich freue mich, wenn es fertig ist.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
wo ich hinsehen soll.
Aber ich denke, es wird gut.
Aber ob das im März
fertig sein wird ...
Ich weiss nicht.
Bisher bei "Auf und davon":
Schommers machten sich in Kigali auf
die Suche nach einem neuen Zuhause.
Ich bin nicht zufrieden.
Der Container mit den Fitnessgeräten
für ihr Studio ...
Oh, Gott. Nein.
- ... liess auf sich warten.
Mit Sack und Pack
zog Familie Caboussat nach Cuxhaven
zu ihrem Wasserturm.
Ihr Umbauprojekt
erhielt gleich einen ersten Dämpfer.
Die grösste Überraschung war,
dass der Lift grösser sein muss.
Corinne Waldburger
möchte ihre Leidenschaft für Hunde
zum Beruf machen.
An der Costa Blanca plant sie mit
ihrem Mann Ralf eine Hundepension.
Wir haben das Zertifikat,
um das hier machen zu dürfen.
# Uf u dervo ...
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
* Möwenkreischen *
Der Wasserturm ist eines
der Wahrzeichen von Cuxhaven.
Und ganzer Stolz von Alain Caboussat
und seiner Familie.
Die Auswanderer aus dem Emmental
haben den 48 m hohen Turm
vor mehr als einem Jahr gekauft.
Also, nehmen wir den raus?
Nico, zieh auf der anderen Seite.
Alain und seine Frau Mirabelle
haben viel vor:
Hier soll ein Café entstehen.
Dazu wollen sie
ein Bed and Breakfast betreiben.
Und ganz oben im Turm selbst wohnen.
Noch stehen sie ganz am Anfang
ihrer grossen Pläne.
Alles, was gemacht ist,
ist ein Schritt vorwärts.
Und alles, was wir machen,
brauchen wir nicht zu bezahlen.
Es ist ein Tropfen auf
den heissen Stein, das wissen wir.
Aber es gibt auch ein gutes Gefühl.
Es passiert etwas.
Die Caboussats haben sich
auf das Projekt mit dem Wasserturm
lange vorbereitet.
Vor dem Kauf liessen sie sich
von Experten beraten,
die die Durchführbarkeit
des Vorhabens bestätigten.
Doch seit sie in Cuxhaven sind,
tauchen beim 120 Jahre alten Gebäude
immer wieder neue Probleme auf.
Mit den Architekten ist es im Moment
so: Wir haben jetzt einen Termin,
zu dem der Brandschutzexperte
endlich kommen sollte.
Wir warten seit ca. vier Monaten
auf dessen Bericht.
Denn dieses Gebäude ist
brandschutztechnisch sehr komplex.
Wir wollen nur ein Treppenhaus
behalten, das ist unser Ding.
Darum mussten wir Vor-
und Schutzräume machen.
Und auch einen Überdruck
im Treppenhaus,
damit es
keine Rauchentwicklung gibt.
Wir hatten das Gefühl,
dass wir das in zwei Monaten haben -
wenn wir es mal besprochen,
berechnet und angeschaut haben.
Aber jetzt sind wir
schon bei fünf, sechs Monaten.
Und deswegen geht es nicht vorwärts.
* Gemütliche jazzige Melodie *
* Möwenkreischen *
Das sind noch Überbleibsel
des Vorgängers.
Wir haben noch
ein paar alte Sachen bekommen,
die wir entsorgen müssen.
Wollen wir eine Pause machen?
* Alain lacht. *
Ja, ich bin gerade etwas müde.
Die Schweizer
haben auch finanziell vorgesorgt
und eine grosszügige Reserve
budgetiert.
Danke.
Jungs?
Aber ihr Projekt
wird je länger je teurer.
In ihrem Zeitplan sind sie
schon ein halbes Jahr in Verzug.
Es macht einen schon nervös,
denn für uns
ist diese Zeit auch Geld.
Man will auch irgendwann mal
ein Resultat sehen.
Geht es in diesem Tempo weiter,
wird es lange dauern,
bis die Caboussats
im Turm wohnen und arbeiten.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Corinne Waldburger und ihr Mann Ralf
leben bereits seit drei Monaten
ihren Auswanderertraum.
Es ist so schön,
seine eigenen Orangen zu haben.
Und sie schmecken fantastisch.
* Zögerliche Laute *
Oh! Die halten aber gut.
Ralf hat einen Mandarinenbaum
gepflanzt.
Einen Bananenbaum -
mal sehen, ob das etwas wird.
Es ist sehr schön.
Es ist Winter an der Costa Blanca:
Erntezeit für Orangen.
In ihrer alten Heimat
in Steinebrunn am Bodensee
ist es jetzt nass und kalt.
Reicht es?
Oder brauchst du noch mehr?
Wenn du noch könntest,
nehme ich noch.
(Lachend)
Ich stell's mir auf den Kopf.
Zwei Häuser, einen Pool
und 6'600 m2 Land
können die Ostschweizer
ihr Eigen nennen.
Platz genug für ihre Hundepension
für bis zu zwölf Tiere,
die sie hier bauen wollen.
Die neue Heimat der Waldburgers
ist bei Auswanderern sehr beliebt.
Viele Pensionäre aus Mitteleuropa
lassen sich hier
wegen des milden Klimas nieder.
Potenzielle Kunden.
Denn wenn die Rentner
nach Hause in die Ferien fliegen,
sind sie froh,
ihren Hund in guten Händen zu wissen.
Mit Hunden arbeiten wollte Corinne
schon seit ihrer Jugend.
Aus Vernunft
entschied sie sich jedoch
für eine kaufmännische Ausbildung.
Ralf verdiente sein Geld als Chef des
Ersatzteillagers in einem Autohaus.
Ihr gesamtes Vermögen
und die Pensionskassen
haben sie
in ihr neues Leben gesteckt.
Wir haben zuerst alles rausgeräumt.
Da waren noch alte Sachen
der vorherigen Bewohner.
Ralf hat zuerst alles gestrichen.
Es ist alles geputzt und sauber.
Wir fühlen uns wohl.
Wir sind jetzt zu Hause.
Schätzchen!
Machst du eine schöne Frisur?
Ich gebe mir Mühe, Schatz.
- Die Spitzen schneiden.
So wie bei dir.
- Ja, ja.
Waldburgers haben fast alles,
was sie sich erträumten:
ein schönes Haus, einen gepflegten
Garten und das Meer in Nähe.
Gut, gut. Okay.
Fehlt nur noch die Baubewilligung.
Dann können sie auch
mit ihrem Hundehotel starten.
Ein neues Daheim:
die Schommers im Glück.
Da bist du ja, du!
Wieso versteckst du dich auch?
So.
Marco und seine Frau Dianne
haben in Kigali nach langer Suche
ein Haus gefunden.
Gerade noch rechtzeitig
zur Schlüsselübergabe
sind auch die Möbel
aus der Schweiz eingetroffen.
Zweieinhalb Monate
waren sie unterwegs.
Ja, es hat Schäden gegeben.
Ähm, hier z.B.
Da gab es Flecken.
Der Tisch ...
Da ist es nicht ganz einfach,
dass der heil angekommen ist
und so montiert werden konnte.
Das ist schon fast ein Wunder.
Das neue Zuhause der Schommers
liegt in einem ruhigen Wohnbezirk.
* Lässige Trommelmusik *
Es gibt fünf Schlafzimmer,
jedes mit einem eigenen Bad.
Ideal für Besucher aus der Schweiz.
Die Miete von umgerechnet 900 Fr.
liegt auch im Budget -
alles wie gewünscht.
Einige Wünsche
sind sicher in Erfüllung gegangen.
Z.B. dass wir ein Haus gefunden
haben, das uns wirklich passt.
Das hat geklappt.
Das mit dem Job
ist noch nicht so weit.
Aber Dianne sagte:
"Schau nur. Zuerst kommt nichts."
"Und dann kommt so viel,
dass du nicht mehr wissen wirst,
wo du mitmachen willst."
Schnugli?
- Ja?
Kannst du mir kurz helfen?
Gib alles, Marco, gib alles!
* Sie lachen. *
Vorsicht, es ist wahnsinnig schwer.
Kannst du es halten?
- Ja.
Dann schaue ich von hinten kurz.
- Du bist gut.
Dann halt ich das mal bis morgen.
Noch etwas weiter hoch. Jawohl.
Warte mal ... So ist gut.
- Ja.
Puh, das ist schwer.
- Ich weiss.
Marco ist Maschinenbau-Ingenieur.
Vor der Auswanderung leitete er
eine Uhrmacherschule in Neuenburg.
So. Das ist jetzt geschafft.
Uff, danke.
* Kussgeräusch *
Jetzt möchte Dianne endlich
ihr Projekt mit dem Fitnessklub
vorantreiben.
21 neue Trampoline
haben die Schommers dafür
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht.
Eines hier.
Jetzt trainieren wir zu Hause
mit dem Trampolin.
Ich bin noch ein bisschen ... puh.
Ich habe so lange nicht mehr
trainiert, hatte keine Zeit.
Weil ich die Container
auspacken musste.
Ich musste das Haus bereit machen.
Es gab viel zu tun.
Aber eben,
es ist nicht dasselbe wie Sport.
Am Abend war ich immer so kaputt,
dass ich keinen Sport
mehr machen mochte.
Also ... hm.
Ich weiss nicht - heute wird meine
Zunge wie eine Krawatte raushängen.
Die Zumba-Trainerin muss wieder fit
werden, bis sie ihr Studio eröffnet.
No! You go there.
No, you go there.
* Rhythmische Popmusik *
Tropische Temperaturen
und die Höhe von 1'500 m
machen Sport nicht gerade einfacher.
Geht es nach Dianne
sollen in ein paar Wochen
bereits zahlende Kunden
ihre Kurse besuchen.
Wasser und Schiffe prägen Cuxhaven.
Hunderttausende Urlauber kommen dafür
jedes Jahr hierher an die Nordsee.
Beste Voraussetzungen
für die Geschäftsidee der Caboussats.
Bis sie den ersten Gast
im Wasserturm begrüssen können,
müssen sie aber zurückstecken.
In Langnau im Emmental
bewohnten die Caboussats
ein grosses Einfamilienhaus.
In Cuxhaven müssen sie sich
mit einer Vier-Zimmer-Etagenwohnung
begnügen.
Wir haben uns eingelebt.
Es gibt schon Dinge,
die einfacher sein könnten.
Es ist noch nicht ganz alles dort,
wo es sein sollte.
Zwischendurch muss man wieder in den
Keller runter, um etwas hochzuholen.
Aber, ähm ...
Man gewöhnt sich daran.
So kann man sich gleich
für den Turm fit machen,
wo man auch ständig
hoch und runter muss.
Das schadet ja nicht.
So, die Jungs müssen ihre Zimmer
jeweils selbst putzen.
Ehemann Alain hat sich
ein paar Hundert Meter weiter
ein Atelier angemietet.
Bis der Gästebetrieb im Wasserturm
läuft,
ist die Familie auf seinen Verdienst
aus seinem alten Job angewiesen.
Ich habe noch für zwei
bis drei Monate ein Mandat.
Ich schaue gerade,
welche neuen Aufgaben ich
im Messebereich als Freelancer
übernehmen kann.
Jetzt muss man halt
mit den Leuten schauen,
das Beziehungsnetz spielen lassen.
* Freizeichen *
Hallo, Ivan. Wie geht es dir?
Der 48-Jährige war bis
vor ein paar Monaten festangestellt
und leitete die Messe in Bern.
Ja, genau.
Die sichere Anstellung in der Schweiz
tauschte Alain gegen die Unsicherheit
in Norddeutschland.
Dafür hat er jetzt mehr Freiheiten.
Im Job, aber auch für sein Hobby.
Alain sammelt LEGO.
Als seine Jungs klein waren,
hat er begonnen,
gebrauchte Sets aufzukaufen,
zu sortieren und weiterzuverkaufen.
Über die Jahre haben sich
mehrere 100 kg der bunten
Spielzeugsteine angesammelt.
Die Idee ist schon, dass es schön
wäre, wenn man das ausbauen könnte.
Ich arbeite gerade
an einer Webseite.
Damit ich
noch mehr verkaufen könnte.
Ich erhalte oft Anfragen von
Personen, die Ersatzteile suchen.
So hätten sie die Möglichkeit,
sich bei mir umzusehen.
Sie sind meist scharf auf
Ersatzteile irgendwelcher Art.
* Gemütliche jazzige Melodie *
In einem Strandhotel
absolviert Yannis, der ältere Sohn,
unterdessen sein erstes Praktikum.
Einen guten Morgen zusammen.
- (Alle) Guten Morgen.
Herr Caboussat geht gleich
mit Frau Loth nach oben,
in die sechste Etage.
Alle zusammen!
(Alle) Eins, zwei, drei,
keep the house clean.
Ich mache das so,
dass ich den Bezug festhalte ...
Nikolas folgte
dem Wunsch seiner Mutter.
Neben der Schule
jobbt er als Zeitungsausträger
und bessert so sein Sackgeld auf.
Ich habe schnell Freunde gefunden.
Mit denen
habe ich auch schon gegamet.
Man trifft sich weniger, sondern
spielt eher online miteinander.
Ich bin zufrieden mit dem,
was ich jetzt habe.
Die Caboussats scheinen sich
schnell eingelebt zu haben.
Komm mal eben. Ich sehe mir
gerade den Akustikplan durch.
In Spanien haben die Waldburgers Post
bekommen: ein Lärmschutzgutachten.
Noch von der Schweiz aus hatten sie
ihren Architekten beauftragt,
die Baubewilligung für das Hundehotel
einzuholen.
Wir haben endlich den Akustikplan
bekommen. Es sind 90 Seiten.
Das habe ich in der Schweiz noch nie
gesehen. Eine riesige Litanei.
Das ist alles auf Spanisch.
Ich übersetze es, damit ich weiss,
was das genau heisst.
Nun habe ich gesehen, dass wir das
Hotel, wie wir das gerne hätten,
in dem Sinne, wie wir es wollen,
gar nicht bauen können.
Wenn wir es so bauen wollen würden,
müssten wir um das ganze Gebäude
eine Mauer bauen.
Also etwa 50 m Mauer
im Abstand von 4 m zum Gebäude.
Und die Mauer müsste 3 m hoch sein.
Das ist für uns keine wirkliche
Lebensqualität für die Hunde,
wenn die aus dem Gehege
oder dem Haus kommen
und eine 3 m hohe Mauer
vor dem Gesicht haben.
Und wir wollen ja eigentlich
einen Fünfsternbetrieb,
d.h., schön eingerichtet usw.
So geht das aber nicht.
Das ist keine Möglichkeit.
Eine Betriebsgenehmigung
hatte ihnen der Architekt
noch vor dem Kauf des Hauses
organisiert.
Die Baubewilligung
sollte bald folgen.
Was uns als Erstes
etwas stutzig gemacht hat:
Das ist vom 23.8.2019 -
d.h., das wurde gemacht,
bevor wir das Haus gekauft hatten.
Also hätte man uns eigentlich
schon länger mitteilen können,
dass das, wie wir es zu bauen im
Sinn haben, gar nicht möglich ist.
Wir waren extra früh dran
und haben das schon
in der Schweiz eingefädelt,
damit wir hier unten dann
schnellstmöglich loslegen können.
Uns scheint es nun, als hätten sie
uns schon mal etwas gegeben:
"Da habt ihr schon mal
eine Bewilligung."
Und jetzt
müssen wir auf den Rest warten.
Ja, das ist schon etwas blöd gerade.
Für mich ist es starker Tobak.
Ja.
Ich finde es nicht so fair.
Für Waldburgers ist klar:
Sie müssen dringend
mit ihrem Architekten sprechen.
In der ruandischen Hauptstadt Kigali
machen sich die Schommers auf den Weg
in ihr neues Fitnessstudio.
Die Strecke
wird Dianne bald täglich fahren.
Ohne den sonst üblichen Stau
sind es nur 10 Min.
Es geht noch mit dem Verkehr.
Wochenlang suchte die 49-Jährige
nach bezahlbaren Räumlichkeiten.
Da waren wir auch.
- Genau, da oben.
4-5 Mio. pro Monat - über 5'000 $.
Und als wir sagten,
wir wollen es nicht,
wollten sie plötzlich
nur noch 2'000 $.
Aber das ist immer noch
viel zu viel.
Jetzt hat Dianne über eine Maklerin
eine günstigere Alternative gefunden.
Ich bin gespannt, wie weit sie
mit dem Fitnessstudio sind.
Ja, wir werden es jetzt sehen.
Die Räumlichkeiten für das
Fitnessstudio befinden sich dort,
wo man sie nicht vermutet:
im hinteren Teil einer Bar.
Hier wird alles komplett umgebaut,
extra für die Bedürfnisse
der Schommers.
* Hämmern *
Es klingt ja schon mal gut.
D.h., sie arbeiten. Oh, là, là!
Okay, okay.
Mwaramutse.
Die Arbeiter müssen Wände versetzen,
die Decke neu machen
sowie Duschen und Toiletten einbauen.
Baustelle pur.
- Baustelle pur.
Und das alles in kürzester Zeit.
Schon in drei Wochen, heisst es,
könnten Schommers eröffnen.
Ich freue mich, wenn es fertig ist.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
wo ich hinsehen soll.
Aber ich denke,
nachher wird es gut sein.
Aber ob das im März
fertig sein wird?
Ich weiss nicht.
Die Räume kosten im Monat 1'000 $.
Ah, bonjour, bonjour.
- Hallo.
Vermieter Hamlet
kümmert sich um den Umbau.
Die Schommers haben ihm dafür
vier Monatsmieten im Voraus bezahlt.
Auch den Zugang zum Studio
wird Hamlet neu machen.
Dazu muss er mehrere Wände
durchbrechen. Bis hin zur Strasse.
(Französisch)
Ja, es ist
eine einfachere Konstruktion,
als was wir beim Nachbarmarkt
gesehen haben.
Aber wir kennen
die Ruander mittlerweile,
und wir wissen,
dass eine gewisse Schicht
lieber an einen solchen Ort
trainieren geht,
wo man sie nicht so sieht.
Das ist nicht so
die Sache der Ruander.
Ähm, möchtest du es dir ansehen?
- Ja.
Ja, das ist eine gute Sache.
Wir gehen uns den Boden ansehen.
Der Boden ...
- Der ist schwierig zu finden.
* Fröhliche, treibende Melodie *
Vermieter Hamlet führt sie
nicht etwa in den Baumarkt,
sondern in einen Laden
für Kinderbedarf.
* Sie spricht Kinyarwanda. *
Diese Platten
kann man als Boden benutzen.
Aber für mich ist das zu weich.
Da bekommt man mit der Zeit
Knieprobleme.
Es soll nicht so hart sein wie hier,
aber auch nicht zu weich.
Dianne ist noch nicht zufrieden.
Vermieter Hamlet muss weitersuchen.
* Sanfte, gemütliche Klänge *
Der Wasserturm in Cuxhaven
wartet weiter darauf,
mit neuem Leben erfüllt zu werden.
Wir müssen vorwärtsmachen.
Es geht auch um die Baugenehmigung,
die wir einreichen müssen.
Alain und Mirabelle kommen mit
ihrem Vorhaben einfach nicht voran.
Das Problem ist, dass das finanziell
gar nicht mehr möglich ist.
Aber Kunststofffenster
sind ca. 60 Euro günstiger.
203'000 - nein, hör auf.
Das müssen wir runterkriegen.
Durch die Auflagen der Behörden
wird das Projekt immer teurer.
Trotz allem: Caboussats sind nach wie
vor fest von ihrem Plan überzeugt.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Das Schlimmste ist, dass man
vieles hört, Versprechen bekommt,
dass die Umsetzung
dann aber z.T. zögerlich ist.
Die Arbeiten gehen nicht ganz so
schnell, wie wir uns das wünschten.
Es ist manchmal mühsam
und beklemmend.
Wenn man nicht genau weiss,
wie es weitergeht.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
An der Costa Blanca
haben Corinne und Ralf
einen Termin
mit ihrem Architekten vereinbart.
Seit Monaten warten die Ostschweizer
auf die Baubewilligung,
die ihnen vor dem Kauf der
Liegenschaft zugesichert wurde.
Heute kommt der Architekt,
der für uns das Projekt
mit dem Hundehotel gemacht hat.
Er hatte gesagt, es sei kein
Problem, hier etwas aufzubauen.
Heute werden wir sicher mal
unsere Fragen stellen.
Wir wollen wissen:
Wo liegt unser Projekt?
Wann wurde es eingegeben?
Wir wollen auch ein Dokument sehen.
Wenn sie es jetzt nicht haben,
sollen sie es noch nachreichen.
Wir wollen das innerhalb einer Woche
mit Stempel und Unterschrift sehen.
Wenn sie uns das nicht beantworten
können, müssen wir irgendwann sagen:
"So geht es nicht weiter."
Entweder machen sie jetzt
mal langsam vorwärts
und unternehmen endlich etwas,
oder wir schauen weiter.
Ralf ist nervös.
Er möchte den Termin
gerne hinter sich bringen.
Diese Warterei ist auch immer ...
* Corinne lacht. *
Ja, das ist blöd.
Mhm.
Aber das dauert -
wie so oft in Spanien.
Hola, Rubén.
- (Rubén) Buenos días.
Architekt Rubén hat seinen
Bautechniker Fillipe mitgebracht.
Wir wollten mal mit euch besprechen,
wie der Stand unseres Projekts
im Moment ist.
Denn Fillipe hat Ralf letztes Mal
die Papiere gegeben.
Und da haben wir gesehen:
Dieses Projekt
ist vom 23. August letztes Jahr.
Er wollte natürlich alles
vor der Unterzeichnung
des Notarvertrags machen.
Genau ...
(Ralf) Das Problem am Ganzen
ist jetzt das Datum.
Das ist vom 23. August.
- Und?
Und wir haben das bis
vor zwei Wochen noch nie gesehen.
Gemäss dieses Plans müssen wir
eine 3 m hohe Mauer bauen.
(Rubén) Mhm. Im Prinzip.
- (Ralf) Im Prinzip.
(Ralf) Nein, das müssen wir.
Das steht so im Gesetz.
Wir müssen das alles
richtig verstehen.
Und das ist natürlich
etwas kompliziert.
Wir sind in Spanien,
und du bist Schweizer.
Gesetz ist natürlich Gesetz.
Aber das ist keine Mathematik.
Nicht 2+2=4.
Okay? Eine Mauer ist das Einfachste,
das Schnellste, das Billigste.
Das ist eine Lösung.
Das passt
mit dem technischen Gesetz.
Das ist nur,
um die Genehmigung zu bekommen.
Ralf und Corinne
scheinen verunsichert.
Erzählt ihnen Architekt Rubén
tatsächlich die Wahrheit?
Oder hält er sie nur hin?
(Rubén) Jetzt hat die Gemeinde
alles geprüft.
(Ralf) Das wissen wir nicht.
- (Rubén) Doch, natürlich.
Wir haben keinen Stempel
eines Eingangs...
Rubén und Fillipe sprechen spanisch.
(Rubén) Aber er hat schon ...
- Aber wir nicht.
(Rubén) Aber er
macht alles Technische.
Er kann dir das schicken.
* Er spricht spanisch. *
Natürlich.
(Rubén) Im Moment müssen wir warten,
bis wir eine Antwort kriegen.
Für ein neues Haus dauert das
sechs, sieben, acht Monate.
Okay.
Aber das braucht nicht nach Valencia
zu gehen. Es ist hier.
Okay.
Man muss immer Geduld haben. Geduld
ist ein perfektes Wort für Spanien.
Geduld.
- Dann warten wir.
Warten wir und warten wir.
Okay, muchas gracias.
- Bueno.
Weiter arbeiten.
- Ja.
So langsam
realisieren die Waldburgers:
Sie sind ihrem Architekten und der
spanischen Bürokratie ausgeliefert.
Ob es ihnen gefällt oder nicht.
Fine. How are you?
Morning.
- Morning.
Marco sässe zu dieser Zeit
in der Schweiz längst in seinem Büro
in der Uhrmacherschule.
In Ruanda geht der 51-Jährige
den Tag etwas lockerer an.
Seine Frau Dianne
ist hingegen schon wieder unterwegs
in Sachen Fitnessstudio.
Sie hat einen Termin
bei ihrer Umzugsfirma.
Noch immer lagern hier
die 18 Fitnessgeräte,
die Schommers im Container
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht haben.
Die Geräte hat Dianne
vom Fitnessklub übernommen,
bei dem sie als Zumba-Trainerin
tätig war.
Jeder Tag, an dem die Geräte
hier länger stehen,
kostet Schommers bares Geld.
Wir zahlen hier pro Monat 400.
Der Besitzer des Raumes,
wo unser Fitnessstudio sein wird,
hat einen Ort,
wo wir unsere Sachen lagern können.
Denn wir wissen nicht,
wie schnell er fertig sein wird.
Darum sagte er, wir sollen
die Sachen bei ihm lagern,
statt hier zu zahlen.
Solange die Schommers mit dem
Fitnessstudio kein Geld verdienen,
müssen sie die Kosten
besonders im Blick behalten.
Auch in Norddeutschland gilt:
Wer auswandert,
muss Durchhaltevermögen besitzen
und darf sich von Rückschlägen
nicht unterkriegen lassen.
Kaum jemand weiss das besser
als Familie Caboussat.
Ich mache gleich auf, Schatz.
- Ja.
Bis es mit dem Wasserturm
weitergeht,
wollen Alain und Mirabelle
eine weitere Idee vorantreiben.
Ein Oldtimer aus Frankreich -
ein Citroën HY -
ist das neueste Projekt
der Emmentaler.
Seit eh und je haben die beiden
ein Faible für alte Dinge.
Jetzt springt er nicht an.
Er funktioniert nicht.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Hast du den Choke gezogen?
- Ja.
Aber der war bereits gezogen.
Oh, meinst du, er ist fast ersoffen,
weil er gezogen war?
Ist die Batterie leer?
- Nein, das Licht geht ja noch.
Das Licht geht noch an.
- Ja.
Alain hat ihn online gefunden.
Er war immer auf der Suche.
Ursprünglich, um so die LEGO
an Flohmärkten zu verkaufen.
Da ist noch so eine Klappe,
die man hochmachen kann,
und durch die Öffnung
könnte man die LEGO verkaufen.
Nun werden wir den Wagen
wohl anders brauchen.
Und zwar wollen wir
Kaffee verkaufen.
Wir werden damit auch
an Flohmärkte oder Märkte gehen.
Gleichzeitig können wir so Werbung
für den Wasserturm machen.
Genau.
Der funktioniert einfach
nur so lange,
damit wir abladen können,
mehr nicht.
Wir sind vielleicht
etwas nahe beieinander.
Ja, schade, sonst hätte ich ...
Ein bisschen kann ich es öffnen.
Achtung, langsam.
Achtung.
Reicht es?
- Ja, es geht.
* Muhen von draussen *
Das ist die Idee.
Hier kommt die Kaffeemaschine hin.
Und hier das Möbelstück.
Aber zuerst muss er anspringen.
- Sonst kommen wir nirgends hin.
Sonst können wir es hier
den Kühen verfüttern.
Genau.
Der HY streikt,
beim Wasserturm klemmt's:
Caboussats brauchen gute Nerven.
Warten zu müssen ist auch für Ralf
und Corinne Waldburger ein Zustand,
den sie nicht gewohnt sind.
Seit sie sich im Jahr 2017
kennengelernt haben,
ging es im Eilzugtempo
durch ihr gemeinsames Leben:
nach einem Jahr zusammenziehen,
dann Hochzeit und jetzt auswandern.
Geh von der Strasse, Schätzchen.
Oh, du bist aber dünn, mein Gott.
Mh, oh, nein.
Oh.
Ich würde solche Streuner
ohne Halsband am liebsten aufnehmen.
Aber wir können ja nicht alle Hunde,
die wir hier sehen, aufnehmen
und mit nach Hause nehmen.
Oft meint man auch nur,
sie hätten kein Zuhause.
Aber auch wenn sie kein Halsband
tragen, ist das nicht zwingend so.
* Sanfte, nachdenkliche Klänge *
Anstatt Zeit für Ausflüge hätten
Waldburgers lieber Baustellen-Stress.
Die beiden wollten eigentlich
kurz nach ihrer Ankunft in Spanien
mit ihrer Hundepension loslegen.
Mmh.
Fleischkäsebrötchen.
- Ja.
Wow.
Doch nun schaut es so aus,
dass es noch weitere Monate dauert,
bis sie überhaupt
die Baubewilligung bekommen.
Wenn man Zeit hat, zu überlegen ...
Da beginnt es bei mir
dann schon zu rattern.
Ist der Weg, den wir verfolgen ...
... der richtige Weg?
Aber ich kenne
die finanzielle Situation und alles.
Ich beginne dann zu rechnen,
was wie viel kosten würde,
wenn wir es machen müssten.
Wie haben dieses Budget -
wie müssen wir das machen?
Und wir haben auch
ein Jahr eingerechnet.
Noch liegen wir im Plan.
Ein St. Galler Bürli.
Schmeckt's?
- Wunderbar.
* Gemütliche Gitarrenklänge *
Wann sie ihr Hundehotel
eröffnen können,
steht zwar noch in den Sternen.
Aber Visitenkarten wollen sie sich
dennoch schon mal machen lassen.
Hallo.
Spanisch sprechen
müssen sie dafür nicht.
Hallo.
Die Grafiker
sind ebenfalls Schweizer,
die an die Costa Blanca
ausgewandert sind.
So wie Hunderte andere.
Seid ihr voll im Schuss?
- Ja, wir haben recht zu tun.
Wirklich? Stören wir?
- Nein, nein.
Kunden stören nie.
Unser Gedanke wäre gewesen, dass wir
dieses Emblem vorne drauf machen.
Dann kann man es aufklappen
und drin stehen unsere Leistungen.
Wir dachten uns: Wieso Flyer
und Visitenkarten machen,
wenn wir beides
in einem machen könnten?
Ah, das wäre beides in einem?
- Ja, wir fanden das gut.
(Grafikerin) Ich würde euch raten,
es etwas grösser zu machen.
Mir scheint es so wahnsinnig klein.
- Ja.
Für mich ist es sicher einfacher,
die Ideen und Vorstellungen,
die wir für die Werbung haben,
auf Schweizerdeutsch
besprechen zu können.
Denn wenn man die Sprache
nicht so gut kann
und jemandem etwas erklären muss,
ist die Gefahr schon gross,
dass es falsch rüberkommt
oder falsch verstanden wird.
Und dann dreht man sich
irgendwann im Kreis.
So haben wir die Möglichkeit,
das so zu besprechen,
wie wir es gewohnt sind.
Das ist schon ein gewisser Vorteil.
(Grafiker) Wir machen
einen ersten Vorschlag.
(Ralf) Ja,
und dann schauen wir weiter.
Auf dem Papier sind die Waldburgers
nun bestens vorbereitet.
Zumindest auf jenem, das sie
selbst drucken lassen können.
Tschüss. Danke.
- Tschüss.
Seit sie in Ruanda ist, gibt Dianne
einmal pro Woche Zumba-Unterricht.
Doch das ist ihr zu wenig.
Sie will mehr Stunden anbieten
und in der Stadt bekannter werden.
* Freizeichen *
(Frau am Telefon) Hallo?
- Hallo, Astrid?
Yes?
(Englisch)
Das ist eine Kollegin -
ja, hier -
die immer zum Zumba
gekommen ist.
Ah, da ist sie.
Und jetzt hat sie
ihr eigenes Hotel eröffnet.
Und nun wollte ich hier ...
Sie meinte, ich hätte hier Platz,
um Zumba-Unterricht zu geben.
So.
Darum komme ich her,
um zu sehen, wie es ist.
Von Zumba-Kursen
und dem Fitnessstudio alleine
werden Schommers
aber nicht leben können.
Hey, long time no see.
Am Stadtrand von Kigali
treibt Ehemann Marco
daher ein weiteres Projekt voran.
Er trifft den Agronomen Barnabas.
Dieser soll ihn beraten.
Schommers überlegen sich,
hier Zitronengras anzupflanzen -
als zusätzliche Einnahmequelle.
(Englisch)
Das Land ist 3,5 ha gross.
Die Schommers haben es
bereits vor neun Jahren gekauft.
Bisher liess Dianne hier Bohnen
anbauen. Ohne grossen Erfolg.
Zitronengras wird zu Duftöl,
Gewürzen oder Tee verarbeitet.
Wenn es gut läuft, könnte Marco
drei- bis viermal im Jahr ernten.
So, talk business.
Zum Start bräuchte Auswanderer Marco
rund 100'000 Setzlinge.
Ausserdem müsste er noch Gräben
und Auffangbecken für das Wasser
bauen lassen,
um eine Erosion des Bodens
zu vermeiden.
Das Investment für dieses Projekt
ist relativ gross für uns,
würde ich sagen.
Es ist nicht nichts.
Es wäre wirklich nicht gut, wenn wir
das in den Sand setzen würden.
Dann hätten wir ein Problem.
Darum muss ich mir schon genau
überlegen, ob es Sinn ergibt,
das weiter zu verfolgen oder nicht.
25'000 ...
Nach genauer Kalkulation
beschliesst Marco,
in das Zitronengrasfeld
zu investieren.
Was gibt's überhaupt?
- Pasta.
Pasta?
Nun sind wir in Spanien, Schätzchen.
Und wir kochen Italienisch.
Corinne und Ralf haben Neuigkeiten
in Sachen Hundehotel.
Wir sind zu unserem Anwalt gegangen
und haben erfahren,
dass unser nächster Nachbar
Unterschriften gesammelt hat.
Wir dachten uns, so viele Nachbarn
haben wir ja gar nicht,
so viele Unterschriften
werden das nicht sein.
Genau.
Unser Anwalt hat uns dieses Blatt
mit den Unterschriften mitgegeben.
Wir haben geblättert
und geblättert und geblättert.
Da sind so viele Unterschriften
drauf.
Unser Nachbar
ist zu allen Leuten gegangen,
wovon einige
wahnsinnig weit weg wohnen.
Wir konnten sehen,
wo diese Leute wohnen.
Wir haben das Gefühl,
diese Leute wissen gar nicht,
dass es hier ein Grundstück gibt.
Die beiden
haben mit vielem gerechnet,
aber dass nun auch noch die Nachbarn
zum Problem werden,
das ist wirklich dicke Post.
Das ist einfach so ...
welche Bedenken er äussert.
Dass quasi ihre Lebensqualität
nicht mehr dieselbe sein wird.
Verschmutzung, Lärm -
das ist das eine.
Und ein weiterer Nachbar
hat Bedenken,
dass sein Land bei einem Verkauf
nicht mehr so viel wert wäre,
wenn hier ein Hundehotel steht.
Die haben dann einfach
Unterschriften gesammelt.
Das sind mehrere Seiten.
Es ist einfach ein seltsames Gefühl,
wenn man noch nicht mal
richtig angekommen ist
und schon die Nachbarn
gegen sich hat.
Das ist kein schöner Start.
Aber in Gottes Namen.
Nächste Woche bei "Auf und davon"
geht Familie Caboussat neue Wege
mit dem Wasserturm.
Wir haben uns nun für einen
Schweizer Ingenieur entschieden.
Mirabelle sammelt erste Erfahrungen
in der Gastronomie.
Sie sprechen manchmal
etwas zu schnell,
und mein Deutsch ist zu schwach.
An der Costa Blanca
versuchen Waldburgers
Kontakt mit ihren Nachbarn
aufzunehmen.
Wir haben schon gehupt usw.
Keine Antwort.
Und dann beginnt
auch noch die Corona-Krise.
Spanien steht still.
- Jetzt läuft gar nichts mehr.
Ganz andere Probleme
haben Schommers in Ruanda:
Der Umbau im Fitnessstudio
kommt zwar gut voran,
doch dann bemerken sie
einen Planungsfehler.
Wir haben leider vergessen,
Umkleidekabinen zu machen.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt
# und chöme nümme hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für nes nöis Dahei.
# Si göh hüt nu uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Regina Kolb - 2021